pero la campaña que se va a desarrollar
es una falsa campaña porque no hay
oposición realmente que compita en este
proceso los únicos dos partidos
políticos que gozaban de respaldo
popular fueron removidos de su
personería jurídica y los siete
precandidatos que estaban encaminando
sea una especie de primaria para definir
que exterior el candidato único están
hoy día encarcelados injustamente y
están siendo acusados del cargo que vos
mencionaste entonces realmente lo que va
a ver el ortega contra sí mismo y va a
haber una serie de partidos satélites
que van a estar intentando dar la
ilusión de que hay un proceso electoral
abierto pero no va a haber una campaña
realmente
señor tfl el presidente ortega asegura
que los detenidos todos opositores
buscaban generar una oleada de
terrorismo como de la oposición estas
acusaciones
son acusaciones infundadas porque
realmente desde el 2019 que emprendimos
la lucha que
decidimos hacerla
lo que queríamos hacer realmente es
aprovechar las elecciones casualmente
para ponerle el poder en riesgo a ortega
y estábamos concertando por así decir
una plataforma loma única posible para
que la oposición democrática pudiera
depositar su voto masivamente y ante un
consejo supremo electoral está cooptado
por la dictadura también y ponerle una
como decíamos nosotros gusano de votos
en contra ortega que él no pudiera
ocultar entonces estábamos encaminados a
la vida cívica y electoral
bajo los mandatos de la constitución
del terrorismo lo hace lo hace ortega
cuando está ocupando lo aparatajes del
estado que encarcela a todo el mundo y
tiene unido a nicaragua en una especie
de terror y una censura total a través
de sus leyes represivas también entonces
realmente
pues la comunidad internacional ha
podido ver que nosotros hemos optado por
la vida cívica y que estábamos
destinados a enfrentar a ortega en este
momento y ganarla y por eso es que
ortega se vio este obligado de alguna
manera a meter a la cárcel a todo lo que
le aceptaban políticamente ortega espera
lograr una nueva reelección en los
comicios y ustedes como opositores
sienten que habrá algún tipo de garantía
para que el proceso sea transparente
creen que esa atención internacional de
la comunidad internacional y las
sanciones realmente pueden servir para
presionar a que las campañas electorales
sean justos
ya estas alturas creemos que no hay nada
que estar con este proyecto electoral
porque no hay no hay oposición que no
vayan 30 están presos los candidatos y
lo ha ido tan de tanto entre comidas son
partidos que son satélite de despegar
realmente entonces no va a haber una
campaña por lo tanto el proceso su
transparencia no no no vienen a resolver
si el transparente o no ningún problema
no hay fiscales no va a haber acceso a
observación internacional ni nacional
desde la sociedad civil o sea va a ser
un proceso totalmente cerrado y la
campaña política que quieren al menos
hacer como remedio ya el día de hoy
salió una salieron notificación
ordenada por el ejecutivo de que la
campaña no va a poder ni siquiera
concentrar personas hasta que ni
siquiera la gente debajo de hacer
demostraciones en la calle de respaldo a
ningún tipo de opción política esta es
una campaña que básicamente se están
cumpliendo como para marcarla en el xx
de lo que tienen que hacer de cara al
proceso electoral pero realmente no
pretende
en ninguna plataforma fuera del frente
sandinista conquisté el voto de los
nicaragüenses